the rising cost of electric electricity
bills no doubt has many of you concerned
8 news now reporter Mary Jane bellies is
sharing the programs available to help
you try to save this summer
like many others across the valley
Chanel Jamerson is worried about the
rising costs of bills including
electricity so I live in Summerlin and
before well before I had him too it was
only like probably 60 bucks per month
and now it's like probably 150. Jameson
has been trying to save money as
electric bills are expected to spike
this July a document submitted to the
Nevada legislature shows rate payers in
southern Nevada are paying 54.2 percent
more for power than they did in 2021.
even the last year it was still like
probably what twenty dollars less or
something but it's still up the hike is
partly due to the rising cost of natural
gas prices Nevada consumer affairs is
reporting the average electric bill to
be around 470 dollars by mid-summer
Marissa shoop the director of resident
services at Nevada hand knows how costly
bills can get for their residents as the
nonprofit helps provide affordable
housing for low-income communities
across Southern Nevada we also know that
about average household it's been about
three percent of their monthly cost on
energy bills but for low-income
households it's about out six to ten
percent and we know that when that type
of percentage impacts their income it
takes away from those essential Goods
that are necessary one of the ways
Nevada hand supports their residence is
through assistant programs but if you're
not part of Nevada hand there is still
help available Nevada 2-1-1 is really a
great resource to help all of our
community access resources we might not
even know are available so it may be
utility assistance or housing but it
certainly is a place where you can go to
get a one-on-one unique resources for
you and your family but for Jamerson
she's having to make a tough decision
I'm moving out of town everybody coming
out of here moving out of town that's
why I'm going Friday you're moving to
I'm going to Indiana because
everything's so hot yeah it's ridiculous
yeah it's ridiculous I just I rather I
rather go out there everything's much
cheaper
the cost of natural gas also going up we
do have a link to energy assistance and
gas assistance programs on our website
at 8newsnow.com